what do you make of this argument that
well there's so many planets in the
universe there has to be the potential
for Life what do you make of those kinds
of arguments what's really fascinating
is that we can make life in the lab that
was one thing that for example I didn't
know yes I should have known but I
didn't know that we can do that and so
if we can't make life in the lab yet we
do not know if small changes in the
initial conditions could actually leave
a planet Baron or if there are huge
changes in condition and still life will
evolve maybe differently because on the
earth we also think it got a couple of
starts but we don't know that and so
this is why I agree with you if you have
like a couple of billions multiplied by
zero they'll have zero and I love if you
multiply by one you have a huge number